escribió una ecuación de suma o de resta
tú eliges para describir el diagrama
bueno veamos qué sucede aquí tengo a
partir del 01 flechita que va hacia la
derecha es decir una cantidad positiva y
va 1 2 3 4 5 lugares a la derecha
entonces aquí tengo un 5 5 positivo
ahora a partir de esta punta de la
flecha vuelvo a recorrer hacia la
derecha 12 lugares así que es 5 + 2 y
que nos lleva a esto esto va a ser igual
a de 0 a 5 y de 567 ya se me dice que no
entiende esto porque todavía no le
escribo el resultado estos 52 igual a 7
ahora sí ya se quitó el mensajito y
vamos a comprobar nuestra respuesta
es correcta veamos otro problema ahora
no los pusieron hacia arriba
escribe una ecuación de suma o resta de
nuevo tu eliges para describir el
diagrama ok vamos a tener a partir del 0
una flecha hacia arriba que me indica
una suma y son 1 2 3 4 5 lugares hacia
arriba ok aquí sería un 5 y a partir de
aquí sería 1 y 2 hacia arriba dos
unidades positivas que se le agregan a
esto sería de nuevo más 2 que nos da 7
esto también lo puedo expresar como una
resta como lo haría bueno si yo escribo
aquí
5 - y entre paréntesis pongo menos 2
este menos -2 es equivalente a una suma
así que tengo cinco menos menos dos que
es lo mismo que cinco más dos igual a
siete vamos a comprobar la respuesta
para que vean que es cierto es correcta
veamos un problema más
ahora escribe una ecuación de suma o
resta de nuevo tu eliges para describir
el diagrama vemos que a partir del cero
hay una flecha hacia abajo lo que indica
una cantidad negativa de 0 a menos 9
menos 9 es la primera cantidad y a
partir de aquí voy hacia abajo con otra
cantidad negativa 12 unidades sería
menos 9 menos 2 y esto va a ser igual a
9 10 11 negativo esto es menos 11
como lo pude haber expresado esto como
suma bueno si yo tengo menos 9 más menos
2 tengo lo mismo más menos 2 sigue
siendo menos 2 una resta y me va a dar
el mismo resultado y para que vean que
esto es cierto comprobamos respuesta y
es correcta